Adam Devine star Jack's a lot of fun
yeah man so I'm just gonna rattle off
some rapid-fire questions for a bet this
is fun this is already excited
do you Siri Alexa or both I use Siri but
I'll never turn my back on my girl jack
see do you think that Alexa is listening
to us when we're not talking to her for
sure they're always listening 100% of
the tiles are they hearing when you're
talking to them this that was the scary
part of the movie when it started
throwing all your cash out oh yeah I was
like they know they've guys the Machine
Zoe we did a like an experimental
interview with a hacker and he hacked my
bank account in ten seconds JD dude it's
scary yeah I wouldn't want to experiment
like that at all
can you do a jexy impression Phil you're
a stupid [ __ ] if jacksie was a person
what celebrity would you hope falls
crazily in love with you well I I mean I
guess you would say like Angelina Jolie
or someone you know yeah cuz she's like
so stunningly she's like strikingly hot
yeah where you're like ah you know like
it's it's scary how beautiful she is
yeah like you walk it with some of those
people you get starstruck with that you
see they're like there's like normal
people and I feel like if I lived with
Angelina Jolie like I would just turn
around the corner every any time I saw
of it oh I'm sorry yes it's you I know
we're together sorry I blocked out most
embarrassing date moment you've ever had
I I left my wallet uh at home one time
then and I so I had to call my buddy and
I'm like come bring my phone I remind
wallet and he comes and it's Kyle knew a
Czech who I created workaholics with who
played Karl the drug dealer on the show
and he sort of distressed like that like
a like a homeless person and he comes in
looking smelly as he does here and he
like gave me and she thought like it was
a drug transaction ought it was like
buying there's a whole thing 'less yeah
and I'm like no it's just a wallet I'm
like
that scary man just came and gave you
your wallet no my oh I live with him are
you still with this girl no no you were
so bad with girls yes well I think it's
pretty common knowledge we can do it by
now
yeah are you consider yourself a good
texture uh yeah I mean sure I I don't
think so I think some people I really
pride themselves on their text like how
witty they are some some girl told me
one time she gives good text and I was
like I think you should just come yeah
how about we have a conversation yeah
yeah when was last time use of bicycle
as actual transportation oh I do all the
time oh really yeah I I could kind of
live over by the beach so I'm always
just big beach cruiser yeah that's what
I thought my first spin class was gonna
be like like it was a beach cruiser kind
of thing but it's aggressively not it is
no no no 100% not why do people send
dick pics well it depends how few think
your dick is awesome looking mine's
super handsome he's like a regal
gentleman right like Pierce Brosnan Oh
like Goldeneye Pierce Brosnan no old oh
yeah yeah
are we gonna see a workaholics movie uh
I mean it's not how it's not not a
possibility it could happen I like that
answer damn it scale of one to ten how
good are you at kickball oh not very
good I actually twisted my ankle playing
kickball in the movie really I was so
embarrassed I didn't tell anyone and
just suffered through it the rest of the
day and then went home and like elevated
my leg and iced myself yeah it took an
ice bath okay finally what was your a o
L screen name
PES man mm not not a joke well done all
right
yes or no if I if you saw these lists
online you'd click on them
top 10 celebs you didn't think could be
aliens yep top eight Pete's pieces of
pizza that look like Abe Lincoln hey let
me cut you short they're all gonna be
yes I'm a sucker for a dumb list so yes
scale of one to ten on you
most excited to click on it what are we
ok alright ok 15 reasons people fall
down the stairs reasons I would say 6 ok
yeah 13 squirrel attacks that ended in
love
Oh 10 10 celebrity weddings that went
horribly wrong - I don't care about
celebrity weddings 6 Rod Stewart songs
you didn't know we're about the devil Oh
10 click on that potato chips versus
pretzels and the other 10 Wars the CIA
is keeping a secret from us okay yeah
that's an 8 that's a solid 8 20 pictures
that prove Jon Hamm hasn't stopped
smiling since madman yeah and finally
these would you rather get high well he
never smiled during Mad Men now he has
to get it all out right since you got
high with Kid Cudi in the movie which
was awesome alright who would you rather
get high with Martha Stewart or Snoop
Dogg I have been high with Snoop Dogg so
Martha Stewart yeah
Oh Snoop Dogg er Willie Nelson well once
again again Willie then Obama or Biden
oh well I'd never met Obama so probably
a llama Oprah or Beyonce I mean Oprah
problem all right Mick Jagger Paul
McCartney Mick Jagger Michael Jordan
Charles Barkley Michael George Katie
Couric Kelly Ripa Couric Brad Pitt or
George Clooney Pitt Tom Hanks are Bill
Murray why you gotta do this to me man
all right bill I'm building for you Adam
Devine jacksie dude thank you so much
thanks man